Tracker may have saved my marriage my
wife loses her phone every single day
she also loses her keys well actually I
have to admit I lose my keys and wallet
a lot so tracker is things like the size
of a coin and you attach it to the
object you're afraid you're gonna lose
and then you can call it and then it
tells you exactly where it is rings
beeps it's finding over a million
misplaced items everyday order yours
right now and you will never lose
anything again I promise you I use it
all the time myself it's the tracker
comm promo code Ben and you get a free
tracker Bravo with any order great
product very excited to be associated
with them and and Thank You tracker for
helping my marriage be better because it
means that I'm less annoyed with my wife
my wife is less annoyed with me and
wants to bother me less